please what kind of a deal would you be
prepared to enter into in the event of a
hung parliament what kind of deal would
you be prepared to enter into in the
event of a hung parliament and before I
ask for the first statement I should
state the obvious ed miliband which is
of course you are aiming for an overall
majority says save us that bit and I'll
go on and no announcer announcer the
Gorton limit of Italy let me just
explain briefly on a broad majority no I
think this is important you know we put
manifesto before the British people you
get to decide in three weeks time which
is the government of this country I
think frankly this coalition government
has become an excuse for broken promises
Nick Clegg broke his promises on tuition
fees David Cameron broke his promise on
vhe now what I want is a majority
government to implement my manifesto to
run this country again for working
people not for the richest and most
powerful to raise the minimum wage to
eight pounds an hour to ban those
exploitative zero hours contracts to
have a mansion tax for the NHS clamped
down on tax avoidance and have more
doctors and nurses and look you know
often this question of what happens
after lecture I've got an old-fashioned
view let the people decide on May the
7th but I want a majority Labour
government I think it's the best thing
for the country
Nigel Faraj I think the most important
constitutional question this country
faces is whether it's an independent
self-governing nation or not and it's
interesting to note that even the
Nationalists believe in being members of
the EU therefore they don't actually
believe in true independence we can't be
an independent state and be part of the
European Union my view is we should be
outside of that my view is we should
govern ourselves my view is which would
be self confident and reach out to the
world so for me for me
if you Kipp is in a position of
influence in the next parliament we
would want the British people to have a
full free and fair referendum so they
can decide whether we have a trade deal
with the EU or continued membership of
the European Union and it's a mystery to
me that the Labour Party which used to
be the party that actually believed that
the EU will be bad for Britain now won't
even give the British people
random I'm astonished by that but that's
what I believe is the most important
thing you keep in Parliament could fight
for Nick Nicola Sturgeon well the most
important deal I want to do on the 7th
of May is with the Scottish people so
that we can meet Scotland's voice here'd
loudly and clearly in Westminster I then
want to see the back of the Tories I
will never ever do a deal with the
Tories let me meet that let's go to you
the pole for sure that it isn't strong
enough to get rid of the Tories on his
own so I will watch with labour with
Leanne with Natalie so that together we
can get rid of the Tories but what I'd
say to add is I won't add to the place
the Tories with something different and
something better something more
progressive because progressive change
is what the country is crying out for so
that's my offer
to Ed Miliband if he's prepared to be
better than the Tories then I'm prepared
to work with him to allow him to replace
the Tories which i think is what many
people want to see they only replied
Kamri wants to end austerity we want to
rebalance power and wealth throughout
these islands we want to invest in job
creation we want to end trident renewal
introduce a living wage and zero hours
contracts but most importantly we want
to bring an end to this Tory government
with its ideological driven cuts and we
can work together as progressives here
on this stage can work together in order
to achieve that we can have strong
public services we can have a strong
economy with a future for our young
people and we can also get a strong deal
for Wales there is no longer any need
for us to continue with a third-rate
devolution settlement like Nicola
I will not prop up a Conservative
government but I will also not pop up a
Labour government hell-bent on
implementing tory policies we can have
an alternative
nationally banded first of all to be
very clear also we would do nothing to
prop up a Tory government in any way at
all but what voters are increasingly
doing is looking towards voting green in
the last election in 2010 about one in a
hundred people voted green the polls are
showing that at least one in 20 and
maybe many more will vote for the kind
of policies we're putting forward for
the fair economy for a publicly owned
and run NHS in which the profit motive
has no place and for tackling the
pressing issue of climate change that
yet again we've not heard any other
person mention on this panel tonight a
strong group of green MPs can build on
the brilliant work of Caroline Lucas we
prepared to work with Ed on a vote by
vote basis but as the an and Nicola of
said what we need is a much stronger
alternative to the Tories and sadly
that's not what labour is offering